Et bien bonjour les amis
Nous sommes aujourd'hui avec Laink ,Terracid et Maxenss
Laink : Coucou
Terracid : Salut à tous
Maxenss : Bonsoir
S : Vous avez vraiment répondu en cœur et avec synchronisation
Je suis stupéfait
Les amis aujourd'hui on est sur Comedy Night
C'est un jeu que j'ai découvert grâce à Laink et Terracid
et un jeu très amusant
C'est un jeu qui simule une soirée dans laquelle n'importe qui va pouvoir aller sur scène
Du coup chacun va pouvoir prendre la parole sur scène pour lancer un thème
ou raconter ce qu'il veut, ou faire des blagues
On va s'amuser
J'vais twitter le lien d'la salle pour que les gens puissent venir à notre soirée
Maxenss tu applaudis pas quand j't'ai pas dis d'applaudir s'te plait
M : Excuses-moi
S : On est parti les amis
Tout l'monde a compris l'principe du jeu, on invite les gens à nous rejoindre
M : Aller c'est parti
S : Mais Maxenss, tu n'es pas censé monter sur scène juste pour me répondre
L : Il a tellement envie d'aller sur scène
S : Grave c'est incroyable
On accueille Krissover, ArKeniix, MONIÉ, Tayoshin, Payl, Milor, Granolan et Damien
Tous : WOUUH
M : Bienvenue bienvenue à tous !
S : C'est énorme
Alors je vais appeler l'un de vous, au pif, et il va devoir mettre de l'ambiance
Avec la technique qu'il veut
Je fais mon p'tit tirage au sort
Attention suspens
Et c'est Krissover qui monte sur scène
Milor : C'est pas moi
L : Moi j'reviens des toilettes et j'me d'mandais combien d'feuilles de papier toilette vous utilisez par essuyage
S : Aaaaaah
Tuckleberry : Alors ça c'est une bonne question mais ça dépend des moments, en fait
T : Parce que quand t'as la chiasse t'en utilises plus par exemple
S : En fait ça dépend d'la qualité du PQ
Est-ce que c'est pas plus malin d'acheter un PQ plus épais mais plus cher
Que d'acheter un PQ moins épais mais moins cher ?
Il faudrait faire le calcul
Damien : J'me demandais, est-ce que quand on utilise un épaisseur 3 feuilles
Parce que on en utilises 3, au lieu d'utiliser 3 feuilles
M : Mais qu'il monte sur scène
S : Attends, attends, attends
Refais cette réflexion sur scène parce que ça vaut l'coup
S : Ok Damien dis-nous
M : On t'écoute
D : Bah, en fait la question d'tout à l'heure c'était l'économie du papier c'est ça, hein ?
M : Pourquoi tous le monde est dépressif sur ce jeu c'est ouf
S : Alors j'ai une p'tite question Damien, es-tu dépressif ?
L : Ou drogué ?
T : Ouais t'as plus l'air d'être sous l'emprise de stupéfiant là
D : Je ne tiens à répondre.. Je ne tiens pas, à répondre à cette question, s'il vous plaît
Je suis la pour répondre aux questions de papier toilette
S : Alors, t'achètes qu PQ triples épaisseurs toi, c'est ça ?
D : Voilà, ouais
S : Donc est-ce que ça t'revient triplement moins cher ?
T : On dirait Evelyne Thomas
D : Bah ouais, éventuellement heu, t'as 3 épaisseurs
L : C'est un génie
D : Parce que, c'est quoi le plus rentable, c'est quoi qu'est-ce qu.. qui, qu'il faut faire merde les mecs ?
S : Beh c'est le débat, c'est le débat les gens veulent savoir
D : On s'mobilise, on s'mobilise ouais, merde, merde
Tous : OUAIIIS !
S : Damien président, Damien président !
L : Ah lui faut l'garder
D : Qu'on déroule, tel un rouleau d'PQ
D : La vérité !
S : *rires*
S : Yes ! Yes Damien !
D : Que la France sache, la France suit honnêtement et droitement
S : Damien, Damien, tout ça la révolution et tout à propos du PQ c'est cool, mais faut penser à déscendre de scène hein
D : Ok merci excuse-moi j'me suis un peu emporté
S : Non mais c'est cool, c'est cool
S : Alors à propos du caca , j'ai une anecdote, quand j'étais à l'école
j'avais un pote qui pouvait pas s'retenir de faire caca mais c'était une vraie maladie
En fait le pauvre dès que ça sentait l'caca dans la classe tout le monde le r'gardait
Et souvent, bah c'est qu'il s'était fait caca d'ssus
T : C'est horrible
M : Donnes-nous des noms !
S : J'sais plus comment il s'appelait
Mais laissez-moi finir putain OH !
Et en fait un jour on a vu dans ses crayons de couleurs y'avait marqué toxique
Et comme il faisait tout le temps caca bah tout l'monde s'est moqué d'lui
Joueur : C'est horrible
S : Et du coup si tu regardes cette vidéo j'sais plus ton nom mais,
J'aimerais m'excuser au nom d'tous d'avoir rigoler d'avoir rigoler
Parce que t'étais pas du tout toxique, t'étais vraiment respectable
Et c'est pas ta faute si tu f'sais caca dessus
L : Bravo
S : Merci
Si aujourd’hui vous voulez faire passer un message à quelqu'un qui regardera probablement cette vidéo
Et ben allez-y c'est le moment lâchez-vous
Et faites vos confessions allez-y
Heakel : Alors Noémie, excuses-moi de m'être moqué sur ta couleur de ch'veux blonde
Parce que c'tait un peu moche mais bon voilà
S : Putain c'est un thug, c'est un thug de ouf !
T : Jordan j'suis désolé quand on était collège on t'avait fait mangé un cookie, tu savais pas pourquoi on riait
Ben c'est parce qu'on avait remplacé les pépites de chocolat par des p'tites crottes de chat dans la cours
M : Oh noon !
S : OOOOH !
Granolan : J'suis désolé au près d'Lilian parce qu'il avait oublié ses clés sur son "pied" et je l'ai foutu dans les chiottes
Et j'ai tiré la chasse et ça avait bouché les chiottes en plus
S : Le fake total
L : Un jour j'ai été très méchant, c'était avec une fille au lycée,
Bah j'vais pas dire son prénom parce que j'ai tellement honte que j'veux pas qu'elle me r'connaisse
On était, c'est une fille qui voulait tous le temps rentrer avec moi au lycée dans l'bus
On prenait l'bus ensemble
Et un jour on rentrait en bus, et y'avait plus qu'nous deux dans l'bus
Et elle était endormie
Et on arrivait au dernier arrêt là où j'descendais
Et du coup j'me r'tourne et j'me dis "merde, qu'est-ce que j'fais ?"
Tu vois j'ai eu un passe, c'est passé dans ma tête j'me dis "merde, est-ce que j'la réveille ou pas ?"
J'l'ai pas réveillé
Et le bus est parti, et j'suis rentré chez moi
Et je pense qu'elle est allée au garage
Ah j'suis désolé voilà, j'm'excuse publiquement
S : Damien !
M : Wouuh !
D : Bon qu'est-ce que vous voulez savoir ? Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
S : Alors Damien, j'aimerais que tu nous dises, comment tu es sorti avec ta première copine ?
Comment l'as-tu séduit ?
D : Heu...
Ouais...
C'était à un anniversaire
Dans une ville d'à côté, bah ouais heu !
J'habitais en province
On faisait hypokhâgne
M : Du hip-hop ?
D : Hypokhâgne. Non, non. Non !
S : Il est mort !
Damien, j'me permet de dégager le grand seigneur de scène juste parce que Arkosis a un truc à dire
Salut Arkosis
A : Bonsoir ! Heu alors moi j'ai une petite question,
Je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand on pète sous la douche beh ça sent beaucoup plus fort ?
J'sais pas si...
Tous : Aaah ! Ouais !
D : On en revient au problème des 3 feuilles et des une feuille
S : Alors
Après ce débat on va rester dans l'caca parce qu'on adore ça
C'qu'on va faire maintenant c'est que quand on monte sur scène,
On dit une anecdote qui fait qu'on s'pose une question depuis tout c'temps dont on n'a jamais eu la réponse
Je m'explique !
Quand j'étais plus jeune, à l'école primaire dans mon cas
Je suis allé aux toilettes, et j'ai fait un caca jaune !
Très jaune !
Et je n'sais toujours pas à quoi c'est lié
Donc si quelqu'un a la réponse ce soir
J'aimerais qu'il éclaire ma lanterne
T : Ouais non mec c'est pas normal ça..
M : Ça dépend l'alimentation hein
J'pense que t'avais mangé genre trop d'légumes ou trop d'fibres
En fait trop de fibreuses
Fin j'sais pas exactement l'terme mais heu..
Mais, vous r'gardez vraiment tous votre caca après avoir fait caca ?
S : Mais tu sais, tu sais qu'c'est important de l'faire parce que,
Tu peux avoir des maladies et tout et c'est ton caca qui te l'indiques quoi
M :  Donc vraiment, à chaque fois qu'vous faites caca vous r'gardez dans la cuvette quoi ?
D : Parc' y'a qu'ça à r'garder en même temps hein
M : Est-ce que y'a des anecdotes où vous vous trouviez un peu con quand vous étiez petit vous savez les p'tites..
S : Ah ouais ! J'en ai une !
M : ..que vous croyiez en fait
S : J'en ai une , j'en ai une
M : Moi en fait par exemple
Quand j'étais p'tit heu, en fait j'croyais que le
Le vent, il était créé par les arbres
Voilà, parce que j'voyais les arbres s'agiter, et j'croyais qu'en fait c'était les arbres qui créaient l'vent
L : Trop stylé
S : Oooh, c'est très mignon
M : Voilà
S : Alors moi, je croyais que ce qu'on avait dans les oreilles, c'était de la cire humaine
Mais en fait pas du tout
Joueur : Ah classique !
S : En fait ça s'appelle du cérumen et c'est un nom scientifique
Voilà
D : Moi j'me souviens quand ma mère, une fois elle m'a dit "t'es bien dans ta peau ?"
Moi j'me, j'croyais que genre si j'avais assez d'peau quoi
Dans mon corps
Bah ouais j'me sens bien dans ma peau quoi, j'croyais que..
Tu vois ?
T : Une fois on était passé avec mon père en voiture sur plusieurs dos d'âne à la suite
Et j'avais peur de d'mander c'que c'était
Il m'a dit "un tremblement d'terre"
Et pendant très longtemps j'ai cru que c'était un tremblement d'terre à chaque fois qu'on passait sur des dos d'âne
Altiis : Quand j'étais gosse j'étais persuadé qu'c'était quelqu'un qui m'retournait dans mon sommeil
C't'à dire que quand on dort on s'tourne on s'en rappelle pas l'lendemain matin
M : Oh c'est génial
S : Oh ! C'est drôle !
Altiis : Du coup j'étais persuadé qu'c'était quelqu'un qui m'avait retourné
Et l'lendemain j'engueulais tous le monde pour savoir qui c'était
Et j'croyais qu'on s'foutait d'ma gueule quand on m'disait "Beh tu t'es retourné tout seul c'est normal"
S : Ooh c'est drôle !
A : Et des fois j'faisais semblant d'dormir j'essayais d'savoir quoi
S : Oh non le mec n'a pas dormi pendant 3 ans pour comprendre
A : Non quand même pas
M : Heu moi j'ai une anecdote mais j'pense que tous le monde l'a
En fait quand justement j'étais avec mon père en voiture
À chaque fois qu'il remerciait quelqu'un d'un signe de la main j'croyais qu'il connaissait la personne en fait
À chaque fois j'croyais qu'il disait bonjour
Et j'disais "mais tu l'connais ?" À chaque fois j'lui disais "mais tu connais cette personne ?"
Et je comprenais jamais en fait que c'est juste qu'il remerciait
Parce que j'comprenais pas pourquoi il remerciait en fait
S : Est-ce qu'on lancerait pas un autre petit sujet ?
T : Hé, est-ce que vous aussi quand vous faisiez les courses avec vot' mère vot' père,
Arrivés à la caisse,
À un moment donné elle vous disait "oh j'reviens j'vais chercher ça"
Et vous étiez en stresse total !
Qu'elle vous d'mande de payer avant qu'elle revienne !
L : Ah et, est-ce que vous avez d'jà perdu vos parents ?
Dans un lieu public ?
Et genre vous avez été appelés avec le haut-parleur du magasin et tous l'bordel ?
M : Alors moi ça m'est jamais arrivé mais je sais que c'était ma pire crainte quand j'étais enfant
Surtout qu'ma mère me racontait qu'il y avait des histoires
J'sais pas si.. J'ai jamais su si c'était pour nous intimider ou si c'était vrai
Et comme quoi qu'étaient enlevés dans le magasin, ils foutaient dans des cartons ils leur rasaient les ch'veux
Et ils vendaient nos organes en.. dans j'sais plus quel pays
Vous avez pas d'jà entendu ces histoires ?
S : Non jamais
Ok une fois j'avais une bouée
Et j'ai sauté
Et en fait j'ai levé les bras parce que je m'enjaillais grandement
Et ma bouée est partie, de mon corps
Et du coup j'ai atterri dans la piscine
Et je me suis mit, j'savais pas nager à l'époque donc j'étais en boule au fond d'la piscine
Et y'a un mec quand j'étais en train..
L : *petit rire qui tente d'être retenu*
S : MAIS C'EST PAS DRÔLE
L : Pardon j'ai rigolé mais j'sais pas pourquoi !
Quand j'étais en train d'agoniser
Y'a un mec qu'a..
D : Une p'tite crevette au fond d'la piscine
S : Quoi ? Qu'est-ce que t'as dit Damien ?
D : Ah j'imagine une crevette au fond d'la piscine
S : Voilà c'est ça
D : Qui bouge comme ça
S : C'est ça, c'était moi la p'tite
D : En train d'crever au fond d'la  piscine
S : Oui, calmes-toi Damien
Du coup le mec est venu me sauver en slibard comme ça
Et heu voilà j'aurais vraiment pu mourir noyé ce jour-là merci
Et mec j'ai vu la.. t'sais mon champ d'vision rétrécir j'ai vu l'tunnel quoi
Et après j'ai vu ma vie défiler d'vant mes yeux
Et anecdote, j'me souviens
Ça m'avait traumatiser pour une seule raison c'est que quand j'ai vu ma vie défiler
La moitié des images que c'était juste moi qui jouais à Dofus
Et du coup, j'étais super triste
J'me disais "putain, si j'meurs la dernière chose que j'verrais c'est mon écaflip niveau 30"
M : Est-ce que vous savez c'qui est petit, qui a du mal à respirer et fini par mourir ?
S : Laink
L : Non j'en étais sûr ! J'en étais sûr vous êtes des merdes !
M : Et non ! C'est un enfant qu'on étouffe dans un sac plastique !
T : Damien j'ai une question, est-ce que j'viens d'entendre dans ton micro un briquet s'allumer ?
Joueur : Moi aussi !
D : Ouais beh ouais j'fume euh, j'fume euh, j'fume
T : Ouais, ouais, oais, vas-y, continues, tu fumes ?
S : Tu fumes quoi, tu fumes quoi ? Dis-nous, dis-nous
D : J'fume, j'fume euh..
T : Est-ce que ça a la couleur d'tes cheveux ?
S : Damien avant, avant d'partir fais-nous un p'tit mot sur scène quand même
M : Damien !
M&S : Damien !
Laink : Une outro !
Tous : Damien ! Damien ! Damien !
Tous : OUAISSSS ! WOUUUHOUW !
D : Au revoir
*Outro*